hello everyone and welcome back to the
last game we'll be showing from the gold
money asian rapid knockouts it's the
clash for third place and it's magnus
cross and versus dingler and now this is
the
blitz section and in the rapid section
since magnus won the first match
uh being needed to bounce back to force
tie breaks and did he win
or what he won three games against
magnus in a row so he completely crushed
him in the rapid section
uh which is uh well just incredible but
uh i guess
magnus maybe adopted a little bit of a
different tactic he only needed a draw
and then it backfired and ding was able
to win three games in a row so he was
able to force tie breaks and now we are
in the blitz section
uh two games of blitz will be played and
then if that also is a tie then we go
into armageddon so this is the first
game of the blitz
magnus has the white pieces now let's
see if dink can make it four in a row
so without further ado let's check it
out it's quite the game i'm sure you're
going to enjoy it
uh magnus opens with e4
with e5 by d knight f3 knight to c6 and
now
bishop to b5 we're going for the rui
lopez we have a6 biting morphy's defense
bishop to a4 and now
knight to f6 so this will be a very very
uh
standard opening we have castles bishop
to e7 and
d3 now uh we're going for the martinez
variation we have b5 now
chasing away this light square bishop
bishop to b3 and the d6 we have c3 and
castle so very standard rue lopez moves
and now as usual when black advances
these pawns on the queen side like this
you want to undermine them by pushing a4
this is what magnus does he plays a4
uh bishop to d7 ding just continues
development and the bishop
back to c2 now you need a additional
support for the e4 pawn
and then sometimes in the future you're
going to play d4 to grab more space in
the center
we have rook to e8 and now rook to e1
h6 biting not knight to b2 knight b to
d2 now
with ideas of shifting knight over to f1
maybe to e3 maybe to g3
uh depending on what black plays with
bishop to f8 now
the rook is nicely placed on the e file
and the h3
uh we have rooked the b8 binding and now
uh there are some games that
reach this exact same position like um
uh the game akovenko versus tomaszewski
where knight the b3 was played that game
ended in a draw
and also there is grand deluxe versus
vojtech that also ended in a draw where
a captures and b5 was played but here
in this game magnus decided after
watching most of my videos that most of
the games that he loses
are due to the fact that he never got to
play b4
so here magnus says all right let's not
make the same mistake again i'm going to
play b4
now so it is only now as of move 14 that
we have a completely new game
so let's see how ding deals with this b4
idea
uh he just continues with knight to e7
he wants to shift
this knight over to g6 and then gain
some control over the f4 square because
this knight is coming to h5 and then
both of the knights will be nicely
controlling the f4 square
uh so a captures on b 5 by magnus a
captures and
now d4 as you now have sufficient
support here on the e4 pawn
you can grab more space in the center
ding continues with knight to g6
and now knight to b3 uh we have rooked
the a8 the ding says
all right you have a nice rook on the
open a file i'm gonna do the same so
rook to a8
and now bishop to d2 so if being uh
captures here magnus can just recapture
with the queen
uh and here ding does capture with rook
captures on a1 which is um
uh usually there's a saying in chess
that you you shouldn't capture if it
doesn't bring you something
uh just capturing for for the sake of
captures isn't really really the way to
go but here it's very hard for ding to
uh improve his position in any way uh
the the position is very solid for both
black and white but it's very hard for
black to find the move
i'll just give you an example for
example if you go knights to f4
uh which makes sense because you kind of
know that white will not give up his uh
bishop pair just just to double up your
f pawn but here it
kind of wins by force because after you
trade the rooks the queen
leaves the defense of the bishop here
and now this is a free pawn
that's that's the problem because now if
d captures on e5
now you eliminate the knight and after
pawn captures you play e5 and you
dislodge this knight which is now the
only defender of this bishop and uh
it's just a winning position for white
so here for the lack of a better move
ding decides the trade here we have rook
captures on a1
queen captures on a1 and now queen to c8
the ding already has two knights here on
the king side he might be interested in
some bishop captures an h3 action uh
just giving up the bishop for
for these two pawns so here king the h2
magnus doesn't allow this he adds
additional support to the h3 pawn
and now knight the as planned one of the
knights can now come to
f4 you can strike in the center with f5
if you want so
black has a lot to play for we have
bishop to d3 now
with uh ideas of well just challenging
this pawn
we might also bring a queen into game to
help out with this
and now knight h to f4 so as planned
this knight is now a monster here uh and
but now bishop to f1
and this is uh this is very important uh
the bishop came to d3
not only to attack this pawn but also to
be shifted to f1 to help out with the
defense of the king's side but from here
you are still attacking this so it might
be
useful later on uh this bishop could be
a most valuable piece
later in the game so here we have c6
just keeping that pawn nicely defended
and now
uh magnus captures on e5 so d captures
on e5
d captures and now bishop to e3 again he
didn't capture just for the sake of
captures he wanted to free the d4 square
for the bishop so now the bishop also
gains
control of the c5 square so bishop to e6
now
challenging the knight and basically
inviting the knight to c5 so knight to
the c5
and here ding captures probably thinking
that magnus will capture with the bishop
and i mean who wouldn't uh wouldn't we
all just capture back with the bishop
but no magnus captures with the b-pawn
and it's uh it's a very interesting
decision it really
uh breaks the you know harmony of of
white's uh
pawns and it kind of uh makes the game
more interesting but i think what it
actually does is
this rook wants to come to d6 at some
point and while you could do this
with the bishop being on c5 and now that
the pawn
is here you can bring the rook to d6 and
you don't have to keep your bishop on c5
uh the bishop can be used elsewhere so
maybe this is what what magnus was going
for
and later on you can always undermine
black with a with a move like c4
so here we have f6 not going for the
immediate f5 this could be
could be a bit too dangerous so just f6
uh adding another defender to the e5
pawn
and now rook to d1 continuing with the
plan of bringing the rook to d6 so king
to h7
and now rook the d6 uh we have f5 now by
ding saying okay
what is the rook really doing here uh
but now comes
bishop captures on f4 by magnus e
captures on f4
and now knight to d4 uh putting a lot of
pressure on black's position also now
there's a double attack here
on the c6 pawn so knight the e5
defending the c6 spawn
and now uh what do you do well there's a
double attack here on the f5 pawn so
let's bring more pressure queen to b1
and this is a really strong move
uh now you are just threatening f
captures on uh
e captures on f5 and uh if you capture
here then the problem is just queen
captures you lose a knight and
if you move the knight for example to g6
then you lose the bishop because then
the knight
the rook and the queen attacked this
bishop here so after this queen to b1
being forced to play
g6 uh to add more protection here
but now magnus just goes queen to c1 he
shifts the attention over
uh to the f4 pawn and this is a blitz
game so players don't have all the time
in the world to calculate but i will
just show a super fun line
uh that starts with bishop to d3 we just
add more pressure to this pawn here
and now black will have to capture
something to alleviate some of the
pressure
so let's say knight captures on the
three queen captures
and now again uh you have to play
something now the
this pawn is still hanging so bishop to
d7 but now we play knight
to f3 again with a double attack on the
bishop
we can defend the bishop but now
knight's the e5 add more pressure to the
bishop
so what what can you play here uh well
you could play f captures on e4
challenge white's queen a little bit but
now queen to d4 now the knight is
defended and there's still a triple
attack on the bishop so it's
just hopeless for black you could try
bishop to e8 but not
knight to g4 and this is just uh bad
the knight can now come to f6 and we
could see something like
queen to f5 but now rook to d8 now the
bishop can never move because you're
getting checkmated
and now also you're just threatening
knight to f6 check to pick up the bishop
here because there will be a double
attack on the bishop but not only this
after knight to f6 check the king will
be forced on this diagonal
and that's just the terrible as the
queen occupies this diagonal
so we would see something like rook to
e6 defending this twice
but we don't care we just moved the rook
from the defense of the f6 pawn rook
captures knight f6
check and now the king is forced to the
dark square at the dark squares and
that's
you know the the the the queen's
territory so
king here knight captures with a double
check and that's it
black resides king of fate knight goes
here and europa is completely winning
so it's a fine line but like i said it's
a blitz game but i wanted to show you
that it was in the position
so here queen to c1 which is also very
strong attacking this pawn
and now ding says all right now we're
gonna go back bishop to d7 now this pawn
is defended and now the knight can move
but now
uh we have e captures on f5 and now g5
this is dean's idea uh he gave up a pawn
to kind of try and keep
things solid but now queen to c2 uh
putting the queen on this long diagonal
thing says all right for the moment this
is not a problem i'm just going to play
rook to g8 maybe i can still do some
damage here
uh but magnus says nope queen to e4 he
attacks the knight here on e5
queen to e8 defending the knight and now
knight to e6 cutting off the queen's
defense of the knight on e5
so what what do you play here ding has
to play something he played knight to f7
he moved the knight
but now it's actually a forced mate in
nine for white uh which
i'm sure you guys are going to find
because only the first two moves
are really important after that it's all
you know just black
trying to survive by giving up as much
material as possible so feel free to
pause the video here
and try to find the quickest way to
victory for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
spotting it and uh well what what a move
it is uh and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
f6 with check so the king is now in
check and
there's not all that much you can do
here because if you block with the rook
uh then you get the well just the the
very impressive rook captures on d7 it's
cheap trick but it gets the job done if
queen captures knight to f8 check just
wins the queen
and you will uh you're getting
checkmated very soon so after f6
check ding moved the king back to h8 but
now comes the move you have to see our
good friend the light square bishop
says again hello everyone plays bishop
to d3
uh and that's it it was in this position
that dingle iron resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the queen to h7 checkmate is unstoppable
and
there's no way uh you can prevent this
and why i said it's a force made in nine
because now some of you will say yes but
you can give up the rook and then defend
with queen to g8
well yes that's why it's a force mate in
nine and not a force mate in three
uh but it's uh you know pointless to
play this queen can block we're gonna
capture here and then capture the bishop
it's just
unplayable it's uh you know a very very
sad position for black
but yeah dingo force not interested in
continuing this after bishop to d3 he
resigned to the game and the magnus now
after losing the first three rapid games
and
the the rapid match now uh leads uh by
by winning the first of the blitz games
and in the second game of the blitz
section uh well the game ended in a draw
which means that magnus is the winner
and he clinches third place of this gold
money uh
asian rapids so it's live on first
artemia second
and magnus in third place so uh really
awesome stuff
uh the the the the game levon played
against certainly in the previous
video that we've shown it was uh you
know like lavon was
creating a masterpiece he was writing
his i don't know what to call it a
sort of a chess symphony uh so really an
outstanding game if you haven't seen it
do check it out it will be one of the
videos that will appear here at any
moment uh but yeah
i mean just very impressive stuff so
like i said this is the last game we'll
be showing from the
from the gold money asian rapid hope you
guys enjoyed this short coverage
and now we're gonna check out some other
things that are happening in the chess
world and also what you all have been
waiting for
uh continuing the morphe saga as we
don't have
a lot to go on there but you know it's
time to conclude things
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
wolfgang schmidt simon surveilla bruce b
backley
mark rappert and paul and miles murphy
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent start
of your week